je fais enfin quelque chose qui a un
sens je pourrais être fier un source
pour qui tu l'as lu ta carrière avons
tourné 6-3 [ __ ] de film avant que le
public ait oublié le nom de la peur
caché dans ce [ __ ] de costumes et là
tu monte une pièce adaptée d'un bouquin
publié il ya 60 ans et toi tu monteras
pour un petit millier de vieux blancs
plan pognon donc seul souci c'est de
trouver un bon resto pour aller dîner
après le spectacle tout le monde s'en
fout complètement sur toi alors fait du
site pour une fois papa tu fais pas ça
pour l'amour de l'art pas du tout tu
fais ça uniquement parce que tu as envie
de te sentir de nouveau dans la course
mais hélas pour toi il ya des milliards
d'individus dans le monde qui se battent
pour être dans la course aussi et ça tu
n'en n'a aucune conscience et tout ce
qui se passe est important aujourd'hui a
lieu dans un monde qui sait même pas qui
tu es qui te fout éperdument de toi mais
tu te prends pour qui à la fin tu
t'étais gelé blogueur tu te moques de
twitter t'as même pas de page facebook
depuis le temps et tu crois que c'est ça
existait tu sais pourquoi tu fais ça
parce que tu as trop la trouille d'être
comme tout le monde
la trouille de pas compter et tu sais
quoi c'est la vérité était insignifiant
ça n'a aucune importance tout ça tu n'as
aucune importance ça c'est la vérité
papin